The threat of rising temperatures due to global
warming will have serious effects on our tiny
blue planet.
Warming oceans could kill coral reefs, there
might be less fresh water, more disease, less
polar bears, more bark beetles, the list goes
on.
But here is one side effect you may not have
heard of...smaller horses.
That’s right, warmer temperatures could
make some animals shrink.
About 50 million years ago, after the dinosaurs
died off, the Earth went through a series
of warming events called hyperthermals, most
likely from an increase of carbon.
Most notably was what scientists call the
Paleocene-Eocene Thermal Maximum (PETM), when
temperatures rose between 5 and 8 degrees
celsius, and stayed that way for almost 200,000
years.
Now, scientists wanted to know how this global
warming event affected the creatures living
at the time, so they started studying ancient
horse teeth.
And they found that, when global temperatures
rose, these horses shrank.
During the PETM, one ancient horse species
called Sifrhippus (siff-RIP-us), shrunk by
30%.
But as the Earth cooled back down, it got
76% bigger.
During the less drastic Eocene Thermal Maximum
2, another ancient horse, the Arenahippus
shrank by 14%, going from about the size of
a dog to about the size of a cat.
Yeah, ancient horses were smaller than you
might have thought.
So, why the shrinkage?
Well, one explanation might be Bergmann's
rule, which states when the climate gets warmer,
mammals get smaller so they can cool off more
efficiently.
Rising temperatures also see an increase in
drought and a decrease in plant growth, which
basically mean less food and water for the
animals, which could result in smaller and
smaller offspring.
But this is more than a fun fact, because
global temperatures are on the rise again
and some shrinking has already been documented
in modern day animals, like sheep, goats and
reindeer.
Now, there are other factors that could have
been in play and the same dwarfing may not
happen the same way it did over 50 million
years ago.
But with some climate scientists predicting
the earth’s temperature increasing by up
to 6 degrees by the year 2100, there may be
a lot to learn from studying these shrinking
horses.
And if history does indeed repeat itself,
more tiny horses could be on the horizon.
If you’re tired of talking about the tiny,
why don’t you go watch this video on some
of the largest creatures to ever walk the
Earth, dinosaurs.
Scientists have completely rewritten how they
are categorized and it’s kinda crazy.
Don’t forget to subscribe, share and come
back for more on Seeker.